Ethiopia is on its way going back to  green the country is facing its worst  drought in decades and trees are  important as they can store water for  dry spells but within the last three  decades Ethiopia has lost almost 50  percent of its forests the country's  population is growing so people cut down  trees to make space for fruits and  vegetables  and the wood consumption for fuel is  expected to rise as well  johannes gays or from ethiopia has  devoted himself to reforesting his  country he collects tree seedlings from  local people and focuses on both  indigenous and exotic species  so far he's planted more than four and a  half million trees and he's already  inspired other groups to do the same  you